what what are you doing at my seat dick
what I'm 11e he is center
[Music]
to get up an endless time
officially the most incredible start to
a tour
[Applause]
let's hear what this Irish accent sounds
like my god okay Stevo he's gonna pick
her street tonight you have to head
along and see him not fast enough
it's pretty good okay ladies and
gentlemen I want to introduce a
mile-high club a newsie ball on it
uh-huh
I can't understand sugars in Oh give you
a little bit Hanuman's right Oh Noli
it's 4:30 in the morning I'm totally
naked in my room and I can't sleep
plus we have to check out in two and a
half hours and get on a ferry to England
yeah pretty sure not supposed to do that
can't tell me where this ferries going
right now we're on the ferry to Holyhead
now our destination for tonight is
Leicester but along the way you'll see
stoke-on-trent and if you thought we
were gonna ride through stoke-on-trent
without getting stoked on a train
you're out of your mind I found a guy
but he wasn't anywhere really near where
we want him so I bought him and his
buddy train tickets from hundreds of
pounds and we're picking him up shortly
we're gonna be so [ __ ] stoked on him
I'll take a bullet for trash
welcome to our home next to mine Oh
[ __ ] it's two stories the bad
ass [ __ ] this is my bedroom
and Scott's got his side
oh yeah then speak [ __ ] no bedroom
made beds yeah
are you trying yeah your treachery okay
yeah all right
come on if I was your journey to get
here do you know why you're here you
have no idea no idea I can well that's
good man you know we're just
I've never been to stoke-on-trent yeah
you got a [ __ ] all-access pass see
you guys are straight [ __ ] VIPs man I
want you to be able to text me if you
need to get on the bus
save it in there drive
yes
your job the score is settled we parked
the bus outside a nightclub and the line
super line and you know our way
all dudes no problem
[Applause]
[Music]
did you sleep okay
Trent yeah yeah sure okay how about you
so there's your poster here is your
steve-o end of the world tour t-shirt
with all the dates of the places we're
going we got your firecracker up the
butt steve-o baseball tee steve-o hooded
sweatshirt your New York Times best
selling [ __ ] five-star autobiography
Showtime comedy special die for knives
[ __ ] life into how is your tube
president
reminds me of my time here in the the
most beloved accomplishment of my entire
life and came dude get in here bro [ __ ]
yeah man you guys made a real pleasure
round never could have expected to enjoy
you as much as I did you want me to keep
making videos like this I need you to
really [ __ ] shows for support man hit
the like [ __ ]
Trent Copeland the our homeboys here we
are in the city of Stoke on track
[Applause]